back to the book store in here about
your ayahuasca trip with Chelsea Handler
yes yes you can watch me vomit
like other than that what's the craziest
thing Chelsea has roped you into after
we did ayahuasca she's like oh I got an
email do you want to go great white
shark diving in a month off of Rosarita
and I'm just like yeah totally I want to
do that that would be amazing and slowly
but surely like pieces of information
about this trip were revealed to me and
Michael Domeier the guy wrong shark it's
like he's like uh well the
accommodations you know it's a science
boat okay right there science boat red
flag yeah what is that
zooming in like a weird like bunk
probably getting lice and then he
proceeded to tell me that the food was
comfort food and I would be gaining
weight for me and then he said journey
out was 36 and ours across I guess Civic
to an island that you know there was no
other access and there was no Wi-Fi I'm
like are you tweet you know what I can't
exist where there is a Twitter so I
pulled out of the trip I called Chelsea
I'm like I'm not going I'm not going on
this trip she's like ah I can't believe
you're doing this I think it's like
really that you're pulling out then like
two days later he's like I'm out too
so then Jason went alone Jason went
alone on this we should Jason off to the
Sharks off on Guadalupe Island
I mean you know what we got out of it
now Jason tagged a shark and that sharks
name is Syd Banks and he oh hey
hopefully not gonna eat somebody little
twin sulphur your little guy yeah and I
just like don't want like there to be a
headline one day saying Syd bigs mom you
know German tourists off the coast of
Lanai there's a question of was it the
shark or the child exactly it could be
both I mean I have some bite marks in
the real siblings right now